ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show here from the new studio I'm
wearing a blue shirt to contrast from
the black background I do not work at
Best Buy but [ __ ] you to the person who
said that let's kind of address the Ari
Shaffir a tweet because a lot of people
are talking about it and it's been a you
know a lot of people are kind of
reacting to it let me read this very
controversial tweet
Ari Shaffir Road Aretha Franklin showed
generations of black people that big can
be beautiful dooming them to a diabetes
epidemic roast in hell monster um again
it's a lot and I can understand why that
angered certain people Aretha Franklin
is an icon maybe one of the greatest
singers songwriters of all time not
songwriters but she's you know she's a
performer she's amazing she's an icon
and I totally understand why some people
were not appreciative of Ahri's
insinuation that somehow her being a big
woman somehow made diabetes prevalent in
the black community and that somehow
there she was somehow responsible for
that IIIi do understand why people are
angry about that and I think that re
does as well and you know he's faced
some consequences for that tweet well
you let why laughing mmm that's why what
is funny about that nothing cuz I don't
think it was that funny no was that very
offensive about Aretha Franklin mm-hmm
that's what people are angry with him
right yeah is that is that not it I mean
your [ __ ] is it is theirs I mean you're
looking at me like I'm wrong what well
you know about the the coke people were
mad at him about the Kobe thing what
What did he say about Kobe
he said Kobe died 28 years too late [ __ ]
the Lakers [ __ ] Kobe he's kind of
celebrating that Kobe died I don't know
if you saw that that's why people are
upset yeah yeah that's what it is yeah
the day dug up the Aretha Franklin
Twitter
they're mad at him about yeah get it up
what he said about coke this is [ __ ]
crazy to me I had no idea
I thought they found in Aretha Franklin
tweet let's see let me find this here
Kobe Bryant died 23 years too late today
he got away with rape because all the
Hollywood liberals who attack comedy
enjoy rooting for the Lakers more than
they dislike rape Big Ups to the hero
who forgot to gas up his chopper I hate
the Lakers what a great day hashtag
[ __ ] the Lakers that's why people are
angry yeah I get it now because I had
thought that they were angry because
they dug up the Aretha Franklin Death
tweet mm-hmm well folks I'm kidding of
course that's our opening [ __ ]
I I know what happened I'm not out of it
I'm well aware of what's going on I you
know I'm like anyone else I you know I'm
like any other American I just you know
survive in a haze of junk food and
self-hatred and then every now and then
I perk right up when I hear that there's
a controversy and I get my ears and eyes
peeled and I you know feel things cuz
that's what we all need to feel things
now we need we need Rage to just feel
it's not enough to be like oh it's a
sunny day we need to feel like something
is being you know happening and
unfolding in front of us we love that we
like a controversy we like a fight we
like you know so I think that that his
tweet if when I look at it I go you know
I would not have said that I mean that's
but Ari is consistent with that bit that
he does where when somebody dies he says
some the most [ __ ] up thing he can say
about the person and he does it
rather immediately like this is what he
does after every single notable person
dies or celebrity dies he goes and he
tweets something really heinous as their
body is still warm
and I think this is clearly by far the
most flak he's ever gotten for it
because this is the biggest person he's
ever said it about you know Kobe's you
know an icon the whole entire city of
Los Angeles is mourning we have friends
that have been really upset because
they've been like Kobe was like a father
to me which that also doesn't make sense
that's also Ari saying the wrong thing
but that's also insane on the other side
to say these guys your day dad if it
when you have a dad you can't that's not
he's not your dad she's what it is he
said he's an iconic figure and I and I
get that everyone's processing it in
different ways but there's people I've
seen on Twitter they've been accused
look remember my family what huh I'm
lost but I do get the importance of the
the guy and you know now I think you
know people are ease parents have been
doxed people are calling in bomb threats
to the venue's he's performing out I
mean it is you know I mean the internet
they they get it poppin they really do I
mean they don't waste any time trying to
dismantle your life when something like
that happens I you know I remember when
Dina Hashem made a joke about xxx 10 C
on the wrapper and she had to make all
of her accounts private because you know
like black emo teenagers were
threatening to kill her or something I
don't know who that guy's fanbase was
but I mean hey I get it I've made a few
jokes about Billy Eilish and you know
people they hurt you know young goth
women have you know surrounded me you
know the Roscoe's chicken and waffles
I've taken many many a beating for that
you know I've taken a
I've taken some body blows for I've just
not a huge fan of the music that's all
um re is a funny guy he's been a good
person to me as a as another comic he's
always been somebody who's looked out I
think for comics he's introduced me to
people he showed my stuff to people he
is not but III do understand why people
I'll never understand why somebody Doc's
as someone's parents I mean I'll never
understand why somebody goes online and
tries to like people that had nothing to
do with this like Ari's [ __ ] parents
survived the Holocaust like they had
nothing I think his dad survived the
holiday it's not only his dad's texting
him what to say about Kobe Bryant it's
oh it's so absurd that anybody would do
that that being said I I know why people
are angry and upset about it and um you
know hey I mean I think that we should
all choose our words carefully when
someone has died that is a beloved
figure you got to choose your words
carefully now you know I I have a video
where I say that Megan McCain will only
have sex with her father and I say that
she'll [ __ ] his corpse she'll [ __ ] his
corpse daddy and that's a video I have
right I say that Megan McCain will only
have sexual relations with her father's
corpse so and it's like you know fun
it's like a funny video to me I
understand maybe why somebody but I
didn't do it the day he died but I'm
clearly not gonna get on like a moral
high horse
like what type of things people can say
I'm sure there's things that I've said
or will say that might get people you
know what are you gonna do you know I
you know I mean I wish them the best
I've kind of been not paying attention
to this as much as you know I should or
I really shouldn't no one should pay
attention to anything in my book just
[ __ ] turn it off turn it off I've
been watching real estate shows for the
past 72 hours I've been watching real
estate shows based in LA million dollar
listing selling Sunset and what I like
about these shows they're not about
anything none of the characters are
particularly memorable they all try to
be that's the thing with like these
reality shows they try to be quirky or
different but they're not the only
reason people watch these is it's real
estate porn and they shoot the houses so
beautifully and everything about la is
sun-drenched and gorgeous and then it's
and then when you walk around I like
even some of these nice houses they're
just boxes and dirt that's what a lot of
them are especially when go over to the
Hollywood Hills they're just concrete
boxes that someone's stuck in a mound of
cat litter and they put little infinity
pools outside and everybody pays ten
million dollars to live there but it's
really when you see it it's not nearly
as impressive as this beautiful
seductive style of shooting where
because bad always tells me all we can't
shoot in the middle of the day because
it's too sunny but somehow the Bravo
team has found a way to like like it's
sexual and they do is that why can we
never do it but they can do it is
because their equipment is better well
they have a forty thousand dollar camera
oh yeah so that's that's what why do you
talk like that well how much
you don't talk like that in real life
you're gonna have to have a 40,000 I
didn't look like deep and I listen back
I don't think I sound like that you
never speak the way you're speaking
right now I asked him back
these [ __ ] shows they're so vapid
and they're not real like none of the
negotiations are real because the
negotiations are all very like you're at
ten five we got to find a way to get to
13 we got to find a way to get to 13
five for a million apart it's too far
which is too far apart we've got to make
a deal work but the real negotiations I
feel like I like listen this is a little
Chinese blood money they can't get this
amount of money out of the country
immediately you're gonna need to [ __ ] it
take a few contingencies on this deal
okay this guy's on the [ __ ] run he
just poisoned a river they want him for
genocide but he loves infinity pools so
he wants his property but he could be in
the UN Criminal Court soon at The Hague
I mean they want him for torture I mean
literally but he adores this property
he likes the finishes he loves the onyx
table he loves it he's got multiple
exposures he loves it as one of the best
streets in Beverly Hills but you got to
give him some time to get the money out
of the country because he's being
accused of genocide
he's just being accused of genocide but
he adores that he can get three thousand
feet of outdoor living space because
that's a lot to get I explained this to
him I explained this to him while he was
showing off the arm of one of his
political opponents I said will you just
cut the buzzsaw down for a minute and
listen to me
you're getting 3,000 feet of outdoor
living space in the hills this is big no
one gets this not for this price point
because that's who's buying a lot of
these properties
it's dictators it's blood money a lot of
this is but that's why the real-estate
show should just be called blood money
it should be called blood money and it's
should be about people talking about
that they now have to sell these
high-end properties to third world the
dictators of third world countries
that's what the show should be it should
be blood money you should be like
there's a lot of powerful people in the
world and sometimes they have to leave
their countries after a coup but they
love the sexy Los Angeles Sun so we're
selling them hot properties sure many of
them have been accused credibly of
genocide and poisoning entire races of
people but one thing they love is a nice
view so come on and swatch blood money
they'll be like the only people that can
really afford these hi no just be a real
trip be like a good-looking realtor with
like hot Manolo Blahnik shoes she'll be
sitting on Sunset Boulevard and she'll
be like you know some of the only people
that can afford these properties right
now are murderers I mean real murderers
I'm not even talking about OJ I mean
they've done [ __ ] I'm talking about
biblical proportions I mean they have
laid down hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people but they're coming it
like Michael Bloomberg I remember who
like delusional people think is going to
be the president like how nuts do you
have to be to think Bloomberg has a shot
or how rich because that's also I've my
friends parents are very wealthy and
they're like we like Bloomberg
and it's like yeah of course you do um
so how rich or how insane do you have to
be to think Bloomberg is a Bloomberg
said about New York City's like bring
all the billionaires we want them all we
want them all and like you have to
realize as a kid but some of them have
done some dirty deeds you know we want
all of the billionaires so what they've
you know poison people in their own
country they like shrimp cocktail they
like steak let him come here we'll get
him a beautiful penthouse but that's
what it should be cold should just be
called blood money you know selling the
Hyatt you know because that's what we're
doing we're just shelling the rest of
New York in LA to people
a lot of them who've earned their money
by grinding people into a paste so they
can have the kind of money where they
can come over here because they go you
know I ground everyone into a paste
everybody's upset about it but I want my
kids to go to NYU so I want to get
something nice and Tribeca you know my
kids love Gossip Girl my daughter's love
Gossip Girl so I want to get something
on the Upper East Side you know my
daughters are just huge fans of the
hills they love you know they just they
just want to watch it so but that is
literally what I did this show on a tour
bus in New York City where we rented out
a double-decker bus and took it through
New York we would point out where these
like rush and fertilizer magnets lived
and these you know Chinese amusement
park tycoons and you know Russian
gangsters and a lot of these people
we're gangsters and I don't even mean
I'm not one of these guys who just says
oh if you're a billionaire you're
necessarily a murderer that's not the
worst by the way I mean you'd you would
if you were throwing a dart board it
because there's a lot you know if you
threw a dart board and if you threw
darts at a bunch of billionaires on the
board you would hit a few murderers
pretty quickly but I'm not one of those
guys who's like oh you're necessarily
like an evil guy but a lot of these
people that were just stashing their
money in real estate in New York or LA
were actually really like nefarious
characters that had you know one guy
that lived in the time warner center had
poison to River in Zambia like he was a
was a mining magnate I think he was a
neat Aggarwal he was a mining magnate
and he had basically you know he was
like you know somebody who had done some
really deadly things with the waste that
his like mine produced any day they
wanted they won they was like he was
literally being accused of like a
genocide or at least like poisoning
River and killing a bunch of people and
then just the idea that
you know he came over to New York and
and and that's why he didn't want this
is why real estate in New York or LA is
so attractive to these people is that
number one they don't buy it under their
own name like nobody gets real estate
under their name they get it under a
shell Corp and a shell Corp is a
corporation that has formed usually for
the expressed purposes of buying real
estate it could be for investing in a
company you could set up a shell covert
to invest in a start-up or something
like that
but usually it's a corporation where you
don't have a feel like the physical
address is different from your address
and it's not you know you have to jump
through a lot of Hoops to find out who
the shell Corp is registered to a lot of
these people have addresses that Cayman
Islands or whatever it's a great way to
just move money around and when you're
buying real estate in places like New
York or London
you know half of new construction in
London has gone to foreign nationals
a lot of it in New York has gone to
foreign nationals you know I think at
one point in New York City half of the
real estate market was was foreign
nationals half of the entire market and
it bumped the condo prices up the
average condo price was like over two
million dollars and you're like well why
are all these people buying all this
real estate because number one's a good
asset it's a hard asset you can live in
it you can rent it out but also it's a
great way to evade taxes is just a great
way to get them getting the money out of
your country it's a good way to get the
money out of the country and hide it and
god only knows where you made it you
know could be drugs narco trafficking
human trafficking d'arco terrorism could
be just you know good old-fashioned you
know the the Wild West of natural gas
and Kazakhstan where god only knows
what's happening you know it's like god
only knows where the money's coming from
nobody cares nobody in the real estate
market cares these people don't care
they're not asking questions I get it
there's not asking questions you look at
these people you're making a lot of
money they're just not asking questions
where the money comes they don't care
where the money comes from they don't
care does it matter does it matter that
someone's sold Epstein that Island
someone sold him that Island there
should be a show where Realtors show
pedophile billionaires Islands you know
and it should be called million dollar
fisting
we're just you know Realtors like Rosa
like it would start like this you'd be
like there's a certain type of person
that loves luxury but even more than
luxury they love privacy these are some
of the top Island brokers in the world
it's not enough to just have an
apartment or a beautiful estate these
people need their own private island
with a private heliport where they can
go and come as they please and take
whoever the hell they want they're
welcome to million dollar fisting they
would just be some chick who's like you
know I was trafficked to one of these
islands as a girl and I realized that I
loved real estate I just had an eye for
it
and I understood why the island was
perfect it was just private it was in
the middle of the Virgin Islands I was
just you know in love with the beaches I
I love that it was just you know I think
it was about 75 acres and you know it
had several places where we could dock
boats it was just it was just one of
those eyes so many of the traffic girls
unfortunately you know went into lives
of crime or drugs but I really just got
into the idea of selling high-end
islands to pedophiles so that's what I
do now I know more islands than anyone
else I know the ins and outs were not
and it would just be a you know realtor
just showing you know showing somebody
around like an island like little st.
James and being like you know hey how
are you guys oh it's good to meet you
how are you hello hi senator how are you
I think you really love about this
island
I was listening everything you told me
and I really started to think about it I
think this is really the perfect
property for you it's very private it
has a heliport right near the house so
there's not a long walk between the
heliport to the house I know that's a
concern for you you know because you
know who knows what state people are
gonna be arriving here in okay
you've got great 360 degree views from
your bedroom so you can walk out on the
deck and see who's coming in from where
and that's super important you know
they've also got a lot of different boat
slips here it's a quick you can make a
quick getaway it's really great and I
just think it's super there's a lot of
underground space which I know is super
important to you it's super important to
have underground space you know
now you could really construct anything
here we're talking about you know four
or five thousand square feet of
underground living space with absolutely
no light coming in it's a very kind of
medieval dungeon feel I just think
that's something that you guys would
really like you know the price is about
it's about thirty million I know it's a
little more than you were looking to
spend but there is some wiggle room
this is owned currently by Saudi prince
but he wants to get rid of it he's
upgrading his operation right now and so
there is a little wiggle room on price
so do you want maybe are you interested
because I could just call him right now
hi how are you great listen I have my
client right here he absolutely loves it
he adores the underground dungeon space
okay we're coming in right now at about
twenty seven five it's an all-cash deal
and we can close in two weeks I don't
know he doesn't love that number he
doesn't love 27:5 I understand but this
is a qualified buyer we're coming in all
cash there's no contingencies here am i
calling someone just calling one of my
friends think I've lost my mind but
that's really what like that's that's
where we're headed hmm with like a lot
of these real estate shows and I just
love them they're hypnotic they
hypnotize you and you just look at and
you know there's these they're all coked
out these [ __ ] realtors is this one
British guzzle look at this house it's
just stunning a sight he's so good to
have stunning sight and you could just
taste a chalk as it goes down his
[ __ ] throat it's stunning sight well
number one broker here in Hollywood
Hughes but that's that that's where
we're at with with television is just
we're all kind of being hypnotized and
just looking at these and nobody's going
to own like the amount of money you have
to have to own any of this like none of
it's even aspirational you can't imagine
it you can bear because it's so much
money that it's like you're put in a
safe distance from it you could just
kind of ogle it it's got its porn it's
literally porn you look at something in
a porn you go I can't really do that
that's not something I can do and I
don't
know anyone that can get in that
position it's just not gonna happen so
you can appreciate it just from like you
know it's impressive and that's what
this stuff is it's just real estate porn
that's where those Real Housewives shows
we're interesting to me not because of
the like the drama or any of that
garbage I just like seeing where rich
people lived and a lot of these people
by the way and that's the great thing
about real estate you look at these real
estate agents and you're like these
people have made money and they're
[ __ ] so that does give you hope you
like these people have because you can't
just be a hedge fund manager like you'd
have to go to school you can't do but
Real Estate's a job where you literally
in the middle of your life if everything
else is [ __ ] fallen by the wayside
you could literally go get a real estate
license and start showing properties and
you might be good at it real estate
agents have social intelligence they're
not that intelligent being too
intelligent is probably a negative to
selling real estate you have to be kind
of a vapid person whose real estate is
vapid you want like like small talk you
know you can't like mention you know it
would be amazing to me to meet all these
people every day not mention that they
all drove through a post-apocalyptic
like la is just tents everywhere in tent
cities it would be hard for me to not
mention some of that while showing them
the house but that wouldn't go over back
because theyíve got to pretend like that
stuff's not even happening just doesn't
exist it's not real don't don't worry
your little head about it you know one
of my old bosses used to be like don't
watch the news the news is not your
friend
don't watch the news don't live in the
real world
that's not the place to live you know he
would just be like just go out there and
but I've always my fantasy life is
selling real estate my fantasy life is
still a shitty life which is great I'm
still a like I'm still some type of like
most people are like their fantasy life
is they're like they're the guy being
sold the house my fantasy life is I'm
still as schmuck they're just selling
high-end real estate to Daryl X like
that's the life that I think that I
should live is just you know shelling
because I always thought it would be
it's the the Commission's on these
houses are quarter million dollars you
know two hundred thousand dollars one
hundred and eighty thousand dollars
life-changing commissions you earn one
commission on one of these houses your
life is changes very few things you can
sell where your life has changed after
one deal you close one deal your life
has changed you sell a five million
dollar house your life has changed for
most people and that is what I always
found interesting about it's like you
and you could do it you could just be
the right place right time you know I'm
not saying it's easy but there's a lot
you know what I do is much harder and
that's not saying that there's a lot of
people that are work a hell of a lot
harder than me but I think it's just
harder to entertain a roomful of people
for an hour then being hot and standing
in a house and having someone fall in
love with it and go okay and I know
that's not all of what it is but it's a
lot of what it is it's a lot of what it
is and obviously there's work that goes
into it but let's cut it out
okay these are brain-dead people when
you watch these shows they're literally
brain dead okay they say the same five
[ __ ] things over and over again so
really unique property you kind of look
at the finishes the finishes are all
updated there's three exposures look at
the view got some outdoor living space
it's really great got a jump on it now
it's been a lot of interest it's not
there's nothing prophetic agents you
meet with agents they don't say anything
profound they're like oh good you're
selling tickets you should sell more
thank thank you good and when you sell
more tickets you'll be playing bigger
Pena's yeah like that Gary Gary Vee the
advice he gave to that tick-tock girl
yeah yeah he he meets the tick-tock girl
Gary Vee goes she goes what should I do
right now we go stay on tick-tock
it's like yeah of course then she goes
should I go to YouTube because I don't
know maybe you won't translate maybe you
will it's like is this advice I mean
literally I'm asking I'm not I'm not
trying to hate on him all the time but
like is this literally actionable advice
to give to another human being yeah you
know the thing that you're doing is
working just do that and then the other
thing that you're thinking about doing
might not work as well but it's just you
know it is the way to give people non
advice
show that I've just hold on did swingers
cancel my order again I would say my
order was delivered oh really you go
check let me check yeah this chat you
wanna keep going yeah I'm gonna keep
going I don't think it was delivered
I have criticized swingers in West
Hollywood because they run a human
trafficking ring and I'm against that
so I've criticized them and I've sort of
suggested that people rise up and as
vigilantes burn the place down
but did we get it okay we did get it
okay well I mean all right well don't
burn the pie was just trying to get
people to go burn the place down
well don't do that now don't do it now
put it down I don't want it now we're
doing a show sit down focus I wish I
could play some of these videos for
these people that would really make the
show a lot better can we edit the men in
post from the actual TV show no from
YouTube which showed the million dollar
listing or the ones you were showing me
is that ones I was showing you there
like long island one yeah cuz you're
hilarious like I want to show people the
difference between is there a way to
edit a YouTube video into that I don't
know if then I think they could pull the
video because it's like copyrighted
because it's on their channel so I think
YouTube can recognize that an algorithm
yeah yeah unfreeze that true I think so
I can post a link to that one video you
kept watching but it's not well we're
gonna do this again when we can what do
we have to do to get that to work well I
mean we need a switcher we need a HDMI
cable yeah we got it we got to get the
TV working because then we can show you
some of the stuff you know like we could
show you that Ari Shaffir tweet on the
TV yeah just show you new you know man
re man God love him but you know hey
sometimes you just step in it he just
stepped in it that's all you know
I'm sure he'll come out of it you know I
mean what do you do do you double down
do you go even harder is that what you
think he's gonna do I hope not
I don't think I don't think he's gonna
do that I think he's probably taking a
step back it might be a good time for
him to go on one of the sabbaticals he
does where he goes to Tibet for a little
while go and take a month you know he
does that he'll disappear for a little
bit and go maybe it's time to just let
the heat cool off let it cool off a
little bit and then come back you know
and by stunning a stay stunning estate
in Beverly Hills hey new year new you
the Tim Dylan show is sponsored by
manscaped and you know what else is new
the engineers at manscaped have spent
the last 18 months crafting the perfect
ball hair trimmer how much would you
love to watch them do this unlike the
Today Show and they've released the new
and improved lawn mower 3.0 smooth out
your scrotum with a new ceramic blade
and man escapes advanced skin safe
technology that means it won't Knick or
snag your nutsack riff on shaving your
balls okay well this is mine now I have
to riff on shaving your balls you ever
shave your balls and you like oh [ __ ] I
nicked my nutsack and you just start
bleeding all over the house huh it ain't
fun the lawn mower 3.0 has lots of
upgraded features making it the best
razor system you've ever owned
featuring an LED lights you can get in
all those nooks and crannies
they've also juiced this baby with 7,000
RPM motor with quiet stroke technology
so no one can hear you buzz yourself
because it's quiet stroke technology the
battery now lasts up to 90 minutes just
in case you want to spend an hour and a
half
buzzing your balls he imagine the person
that spends 90 minutes
working on their package can you imagine
the charging stand is not powered by USB
it couldn't be easier to use if you have
the manscape 2.0 razor it's easy you can
use the same replacement blade from the
3.0 upgrade yourself get 20% off and
free shipping when you use the code t IM
at manscape comm thats manscape comm and
use a promo code t IM for 20% off your
first order get manscaped and keep your
balls clean and 2020 okay here's the
deal
you need this product if you are male or
you identify as a male you need to clean
up your package there's a few products
like this there's a norelco body groom
and then there is this thing the
lawnmower 3.0 the body groom is not
great the lawnmower is a much better
product it insulates you from nicking
yourself cutting yourself it is better I
use it they send me a bunch I've given
them to friends it is the highest tech
on the market for shaving your balls
that's the way it is so if you're going
to use a product like this you might as
well use this use promo code t IM you
get 20% off your first order I'm telling
you you might as well 20% off your first
order you're not going to get that deal
with norelco you're not gonna get that
deal with any other razor this is a
professional razor they've put a lot of
thought into this into how you can shave
your balls for 90 minutes if need be
skin save technology quite stroke
technology I mean what do you want you
should get this it's a great way to get
a great product it's really you know
important that you use the promo code so
they know that where we're sending you
to the website that you're supporting
our program and it's also a great way to
just clean
your package you know a lot of people
aren't having sex right now they're just
not having sex you know there's too much
porn out there they're on SSRIs they
can't get hard for whatever reason they
don't know how to talk to women they're
lonely they're lonely people and they're
being radicalized online and you know on
the dark web or wherever they go even on
the you know on the there's plenty of
things on the regular web that'll
that'll get you going so instead of
doing that instead of becoming a
psychopath maybe you should try to have
sex with someone that you are attracted
to and that will prevent you from
spending hours and hours and hours
reading about the shapes of skulls it's
a thought
it's thought I don't know maybe it won't
work but it could so I think it's a
great way to just try just give it a
shot
manscape comm promo code t IM for 20%
off your first order thank you
there's just you know I said this on the
patreon the other day I don't really get
that upset with what people say because
I know how cheap words are and most
people that are talking to you are lying
and making things up most people are
trying to make themselves sound more
interesting by lying they'll they'll
make up things it never happened to them
and they'll say it they'll tell you
stories from movies that they think you
didn't see and then try to pretend that
they lived through them this is how
desperate most human beings are for any
level of attention they just don't care
so words to me don't mean anything
literally no matter what you say I
understand that words of course do mean
things but I always I'm very cynical
unless you show me something unless I'm
able to deduce like what you say to me
is is is absolutely for the most part as
you relevant is anything
when people just pop off and talk I mean
I just I have friends that I like that I
know are pathological liars that will
sit at a table with you and make up
something that's just completely untrue
and get called out on it and really
don't have they don't have any shame
this is just you know I assume when
people are talking to me I assume that
most of them are lying I just assume
you're making you're making something up
and then if I eat turns out to be true I
go nice if it turns out to be an
actually true thing I go oh that's
that's nice you know I just you can't
trust people because all they're trying
to do is be funny or interesting and
they'll say anything people literally
just say anything people talk about
things they have no idea what they're
talking about and they just go they just
go there's no shame they just they just
go they just go right they just let it
out let doesn't matter they don't have
to know about how many times do we sit
in a room and some people start talking
to Rogen about fighting they start
telling him what the deal is he said
what are you saying shut up will you
shut up they don't care they just talk
cuz they don't know what else to do
they're very uncomfortable with silence
mmm so they just they just talk yeah
I've members of my family like that they
don't know anything and they say
ridiculous things because people don't
call them out and they just say things
you don't make any sense you know yes
just let it happen you can't get angry
people get angry the boomers go on
Facebook and light it up it cares it's
funny they're crazy they're almost dead
they just they've never had a platform
like this where they could just just
launch they could just go it used to be
a corner bar now it's Facebook they
could just launch they don't need to
have the facts doesn't matter to them
they want to be heard boomers by the way
it's the first generation that has a
[ __ ] ton of life experience and and and
and and and and no wisdom I feel like
I've been on this planet a long time
it's and you ruined it shut the [ __ ] up
half of you not all of you but a lot of
you should just pipe down just go out
quietly you destroy it's like you
inherit a house you burn the house down
just leave quietly just exit quietly
don't be loud on the way out it burned
it down you know and that's not everyone
but you know let them let them launch on
Facebook let them pop off anyone still
on Facebook in any meaningful sense
right now ISM is a mental patient and I
mean that if you're on Facebook trying
to make a point you're nuts
it's oh it's a graveyard I see people
that I like kind of respect on fate and
they go into these multi paragraph
things on Facebook and the trilling well
here's what I Sears how I see here's our
eyes yeah
could there be anything less appropriate
than your take on Facebook there's
nothing to say anymore
on that site it's like the people still
there are sick you're convincing sick
people my mother is in a mental
institution they're all more
well-adjusted than my Facebook Timeline
people talk about drama in these little
comedy community no one cares about your
drama in burnt corn Alabama's comedy
scene stop talking about the open mic
that banned you because you used a word
oriental and then you and did nine other
people in that scene you're gonna have a
2000 comment thread about free speech
after the or anything you can people
doing these big comment threads about
fries be shut the [ __ ] up you also have
the freedom to not speak does it affect
you you're unaffected by this you don't
need to go into all but this is what
people do when and I've said it before
they're feral they've been bit social
media has given them this idea that they
have to have a take on things just just
let it go does it no one gives a [ __ ]
about what you're saying calm down
it's crazy stop posting libertarian
memes if you live with your mother
stop talking about a bad socialism is if
you live with your mother get out of
your how these Long Island guys live
with their mom socialism is burn
cropland will you shut up you're eating
cereal that someone bought for you
you're on a family plan you and you
about you're in your 30s
it's like that's what Facebook is it's
like people have authority okay I'll you
my favorite ones that go get off my page
take that off my page this is my page I
don't own a house but I own this page I
this page where I can enforce the rules
go I have it to sell some tickets to put
some merch out there but there was a lot
I had a lot of fun with it back in the
day I used to write these long things
troll people there was a lot of fun but
it's over now and if you 96 you know
don't be on tech not like maybe we'll
all have to be on tick-tock there's just
something super sad about seeing old
people on that app I know that we have
to get on it probably for our careers
but there's something sad about it but
you know you feel odd being on examines
15 it's like I'm not really trying to
entertain 15 year-olds I don't care I
don't know you you shouldn't think I'm
funny
you can't buy tickets to my show you
there's we're not doing anything here
there's no overlapping life experiences
of me and you
you were born after 9/11 you know what I
mean
I was born before 9/11 and then I
learned that 9/11 wasn't real so yeah
we're never gonna yeah I'm not doing
your new dance on tick-tock okay
i watch the Towers fall and then found
out they were Holograms I am NOT doing
you dance
I'm not doing you fortnight dance okay
I'm awake you don't get it you've little
punk [ __ ] you don't know what it's like
to listen to people talk about lizard
people then find out they're right me
and Ray were saying this is why people
go so [ __ ] nuts me and Ray and you
have [ __ ] everything we knew I [ __ ]
all government was but then most people
just found out about it with kid [ __ ]
so that's that's how their minds melted
because if you know how banner about
Kennedy and about all of these coos that
we did if you knew about these
democratically if you knew about how
fake everything was and the murder an
assassination of blackmail you knew this
[ __ ] the CIA was into if you paid
attention if you'd read any of those
books if you knew oh you know our
appetite for skullduggery and the things
that we had done to other people
children if you knew about MKULTRA if
you knew about that [ __ ] then once you
got to the pedophile cults and Epstein
you were kind of like ah yeah this is a
heinous
but logical conclusion to the
infrastructure the groundwork that we
already laid in our mind but if you just
arrived at that your mind melts and
that's what you're seeing is people's
minds melt see like oh [ __ ]
wait watch it's crazy if your entrance
point into how [ __ ] up everything is
is your private islands were politicians
or [ __ ] kids your mind will melt and
I'm not saying it's not shocking if you
if you knew other things but it's less
shocking if you knew what these people
are capable of if you just know what
they're capable of you're not like
you're like yeah this is what we had
thought it could be and it is that but
that's what people's mind you're
mouthing and they're they don't know
what to do
so I think that's where the Qi on stuff
comes in it's like they're just looking
to believe thanks you know they're
looking to they're like well I hope to
god that everything's you know but now
it'll be okay right you're like but now
cuz that's what all these things are
like but now it's good because now we're
in there's the secret war that's hatton
you're like well I don't know hopefully
you're right hopefully there is a sequel
I don't you know what am I telling you I
would love if there was a secret war and
good people won great you know but I
just you know it's like thinking that
Donald Trump is leading that war to me
is I almost have to believe that one of
these realtors on Bravo is doing it
because there's it's the same type of
person they I would almost have to
believe that you know yeah one of the
guys from million-dollar listing is uh
fighting a secret war to free all the
kids that are being [ __ ] really good
you would say good you'd go bad the guy
from million dollar listing that showed
the house the big house with the rooftop
pool he's doing the secret war oh well
I'm happy about that I'm not against
that I'm for that if it's happening I'm
for it
I you know I have no investment in it
not happening good you know that's what
Ari Shaffir has to do to get in
everyone's good graces he's got to
figure out who killed Epstein Ari's got
to solve the Jeffrey Epstein murder and
then come back with a fire tweet naming
the perpetrator John McAfee did it
recently he's like it was dark Taglioni
it was just prison guard and we're
piecing the other things together he's
like if you know how it happened I'll
buy you dinner it's like okay
Prince Andrew not cooperating that's a
shock it's a shock
to shock they're still trying like
they're still there's still elements I'm
sure the FBI that have some good people
in them and there's still like trying to
there's you know we wish everyone luck
you just lay Maxwell in a few years will
be somebody buying a house in one of
these Bravo real-estate shows you know
they'd be law is one thing I know about
your slide she loves a stunning a sty
she's lying is a socialite she's made of
money hanging out people in a law style
so I'm gonna show her house in the bird
streets the birds feature like the hot
Hollywood Hills you people don't know
the truth Dale Estates a lot of this
stuff is gated when I was a kid I grew
up we used to drive through wealthy
areas and smoke pot in the car and
that's how you know why privilege it's
annoying to hear but it is true because
I literally used to get high and look at
all my friends ago I want to see the
mansions and we would just drive around
mansions just stoned and on other things
and then we just get out of the car
sometimes like creep creep up the lawn
of these old mansions I'd be smoking a
cigarette I'm like look at this property
it's gorgeous
weed I was driving through Sands Point
Long Island I was smoking pot my buddy
tom was now works for the government
he's like a US Marshal and we were
driving and we had the windows down
we're smoking pot driving through all
these mansions and I was just screaming
top my luck these people are so much
better than us there's so much better
than us
and I wasn't kidding I was awake and
aware and and I got and that was fun you
can't do that in California cause of the
goddamn gates these [ __ ] scaredy cats
they always need to be behind the gates
but in Long Island a lot of those areas
weren't gated so you could drive around
you know all coked out look at Christmas
lights there was something nice to be
coked out and look at Christmas lights
it's much nicer when you're stoned
obviously it's nicer it's nice when
you're stoned you have a little hot
chocolate from Dunkin Donuts and you can
go look at the lights so fun baby baby
you got a ridge wallet no you don't have
a ridge wallet what are you like a piece
of [ __ ] Ridge is the [ __ ] best it is
a small front pocket wallet
it comes in titanium carbon fiber
aluminum and over a dozen different
styles and colors I've talked about this
before one of the most embarrassing
things about my dad was used to pull out
this old leather wallet with business
cards of people he'd never done business
with and they'd all fall out and he'd
have a bunch of ones that he stuffed in
there just stripper money stuffed right
into the wallet and it was filthy it was
disorganized it made him look
unsuccessful you don't want that you
want a streamline tight sharp Ridge
wallet that only has a few debit cards
and a credit card or a cashless society
maybe maybe a $100 bill something really
crisp you throw in there but the great
thing about a Ridge wallet is it forces
you to organize your life you don't have
this big cumbersome you know ball of
[ __ ] in your pocket that you don't need
okay you have something that is
streamlined and it encourages it
necessitates you to start looking at
what is and isn't an actual necessity in
your life now we've talked about this
before it starts with Ridge wallet but
then it goes to people who do you really
need in your life who needs to get out
where do you really need to go you know
what do you really need to do is the job
you're at there I mean everything starts
with your wallet
everything starts with choices be in you
know be Adam every choice in life that
you have should be intentional you
should say to yourself I want to do
something and then you do it and
something about a Ridge wallet and I
have a Ridge wallet there's something
about it that really forces you to to
basically strip your life down to the
bare essentials because that is what we
all need we need essentials my mother
was a hoarder
we had rooms in my house that were just
stacked up shoeboxes filled with beanie
babies McDonald's toys has trucks okay
that we're gonna get sold in the after
market never can never never
materialized never came to fruition
my mother's retirement plan never worked
i thank god she's in a mental
institution she doesn't really need one
but what I'm saying is that a Ridge
wallet prevents that that type of
thinking doesn't exist when you have a
Ridge wallet okay it's very easy you got
to use promo code Tim ego Ridge comm /t
I am use TI em it's the link in the
description okay they've been sponsoring
our podcast we're very proud to be in a
business with them in business with them
we like them they're good people
they put out a good product people are
happy with it can they buy the backpacks
- yeah not with the code but they can
still buy their backpacks I need the
code for the backpack enough you get the
code for the wallet okay
10% off free worldwide shipping and
returns if you don't like it doesn't
matter where you are it doesn't matter
what radical group you're part of that
you're listening to the show
they'll send your Ridge wallet gold and
dawn over there and I think it's a it's
a right-wing group in Greece I don't
know
the point is I'm just picking out of the
sky no matter where you are maybe you're
a special ops guy and you're hanging out
in Africa just you know helping those
people on behalf of the United States
government and you need a Ridge wallet
well then you get one free worldwide
shipping maybe you were in Syria waiting
for it to pop off again cuz that'll be
coming in about six months
who knows maybe you're in the Ukraine
pissing putin off trying to start some
[ __ ] you know get a ridge wallet will
ship it to you and you can return it if
you don't like it but i think you'll
love it free returns means they are
confident that you're gonna love the
ridge wallet doesn't matter where you
are you could be in america you could be
in any country's world
this is a worldwide company Ridge wallet
is baller [ __ ] people it's a
conversation starter people like what is
that you go it's my [ __ ] Ridge wallet
they go Wow
then you start talking about this show
you go I listen to the Tim Dillon show I
purchased a ridge wallet
it's been great like what do you mean
the Tim village right now of course they
know what it is I'm lying I'm making
this up there you go they usually go oh
I love that show or they go my family
list is that show I don't listen to that
show but I should everyone tells me it's
so funny Tim Dylan's a genius is that
true when somebody goes well of course
it is this is what happened and then
maybe there's an attractive woman at the
bar and she just says to you oh you you
what do you list it Tim Dylan show you
got a ridge wallet you're a [ __ ]
you're I want to have sex with you and I
want to have children with you and I
want to build a life with you and I will
be faithful to you and you don't have to
be faithful to me I don't expect that I
don't expect that because you're too
attractive and successful all of this
started because you had a ridge wallet
all of those things happen okay now of
course that's not gonna happen for
everyone I mean more likely you get the
ridge wallet you take it out you're
playing with it and then you know the
guy Duncan Donna says we're closing they
start flicking the lights on and off
tell you to get out you know and you're
not listening because you have your
earbuds in and you're listening to the
podcast and the guy has to come over you
and you guys to lightly start shaking
motioning the door it's time to go
because it's you know the results are
different we can't guarantee the results
of the ridge wallet you know many of you
will purchase this and still have
horrible lives I mean horrible but some
of you this will this will this will
turn it around and are you willing to
take that chance you should be you
should be I'm telling you right now my
dad bought a million of these and didn't
use the promo code thank you he didn't
he bought it for everyone he knows and
he does not use the promo code so it
doesn't help me at all but then he goes
well I'm sure it helps somehow and I go
it does not it does not but again that's
the boomer mentality of like hey it's
the thought that counts
no it's not it's actually not the
thought that's ever counted
that's the whole generation they believe
that's the thought the cat's no it
doesn't not at all not at all the
thought that counts it's actually what
you do that counts okay but they don't
care they don't golf oh I don't care
doesn't matter to them I'm sure it helps
no but thanks anyway thanks for trying
that's okay I appreciate it
rage calm slash Tim T I am use code T I
am for the love of God
use the code don't [ __ ] get it
without the code use the code that's why
we have a code you'll get 10% off and
more importantly they'll know that you
got there from my goddamn show don't
tell me that you didn't use the code be
methodical use the code don't be like my
dad great guy but doesn't use the
[ __ ] code use the code the code is
your friend the code is here to help you
and and help me that's why we need codes
codes are good promo codes are good
they're exclusive don't you want to be
in the club the Bohemian Grove you can't
get that but here's what you can do you
can get a [ __ ] Ridge wallet with the
code TI m so use the goddamn code please
don't message me as many people have and
say I forgot to use the code I hope this
counts it doesn't count how many times
do out there how in God's name would it
count they don't know where you're
showing up from the code is essential so
that I get credit for what you do and it
end the code is essential for you to get
to ten percent off okay that's the
important thing
so let's all use the code and the code
is T I am it's not confusing it's just
my name t IM easy isn't it easy all of
you can remember and hopefully spell the
Tim so let's please use that code one
more time Ridge comm /t I M to buy the
[ __ ] wallet when you purchase the
[ __ ] wallet you'll get 10% off today
with free worldwide shipping and returns
that means shipping to anywhere in the
world and returns from anywhere in the
world
that's what worldwide means thank you to
our partners over at Ridge it's a new
year it's a new time for all of the
people out there to get a [ __ ] wallet
that's it thank you so fun there's very
you really smoking pot it's supposed to
be when you're in your late teens or
early twenties that's what it's for
stop doing it if you're older than that
it's an enough already enough you know I
get it that you people can't put it down
but put it down it'll never be as much
fun oh I started smoking pot at 32 oh
okay you [ __ ] loser
enough it's for children it's for teens
and young adults that's when it's the
most fun you don't need to be doing it
for your entire life your mind will melt
trust me you just don't need to do it
it's not the move there's other things
to do and I know this is super
controversial because there's a lot of
people who listen to this show the love
weed just just try try a little time
without it just space it out a little
bit take a hit every now and then you
know you don't you stop there's
something weird about being in your 30s
and it's like everything's about weed
something odd about that grow up you
know drink wine take pills take pills
and drink wine get drunk OD in your bed
die do something adult for once be a
[ __ ] adult do something dolt like get
a drinking problem and lose your kids
that's what adults do
they don't [ __ ] smoke pot talk about
disappointing the new Star Wars was lose
your firm snort your house destroy your
shelf with pharmaceuticals I don't care
I'm not telling you to be a moralist but
enough with being a [ __ ] you know
pothead when you're in your mid-30s grow
the [ __ ] up I smoke to go to sleep will
deal with your demons make peace with
the monster under the bed to feed him be
him I'm just yelling this there's just a
kindergarten class looking at me like
this was an appropriate time and this
wasn't really great you know but that
I've had enough with the weed living in
LA every snows a weed store that's the
only thing left in this economy is the
tick tock and weed that's all that's
left
it's just people dancing and and and
edibles nobody can live anymore unless
they're shoving an edible down their
throat how did we all sleep before weed
I need an edible so I can eat and sleep
what so problem it's a serious problem
little our friend that k2 runs our
website little Alex they were gonna
start making him smoke weed because he's
like very tiny for like medical reasons
right yeah because he can like eat he
fills up very quickly and he needs to
like blow himself up because he's like
this tiny little bird-like creature and
he needs to just get bigger so what he
needs to do with smoke weed so we just
eats brownies and stretches his stomach
out or something okay I don't know I
don't know how it works folks I'm just
saying
I'm not trying to I don't want the wrath
of the weed people here I'm just saying
it's [ __ ] do something adult you know
and there's nothing adult but like
there's something adult about developing
an addiction to painkillers there's
something classy about a nice corporate
pill slides right down little feed
little Fiji water you slide that sexy
pill down your throat
and you just light up a little sig lady
and you have fun stop the nature weed
shed embrace the Sackler family embrace
go sometimes I wonder sometimes I wonder
like what if there are impressionable
people that listen to this like I'm I'm
joking now but I'm also serious in a way
like I don't like the weed culture is
not for me it's grotesque
it's truly grotesque people that sell
weed are stupid when you when they're
when they're out and they start talking
about their weed company you wanted to
throw yourself in front of a car because
or you want to throw them in front of a
car they're uninteresting people okay
they just talk about with my friend
Michael took a weed all the time you
know and he tries to make it sound like
he's you know building a supercomputer
it's like you shut the [ __ ] up
yeah people you have weed and people
smoke and I get the fundamentals of the
business I get what it is oh you put
weed in the gummy bear now you put it in
a meatball you put it in a brownie I
know what you're doing about you don't
have to go on like your Warren Buffett a
weed and talk about how fascinating whoa
we got a lot of shop you got grow or
grow operation or do it shut up we don't
need your mouth shut up with the weed
business uh 'king interesting a be
interesting if you're working with the
cartel the [ __ ] it chopping people's
heads off but it's not [ __ ]
interesting when you [ __ ] tell me
you're having a problem to your graphic
designer just [ __ ] kids are we hard
not working hard Rosalie shut up
I can listen my [ __ ] friends talk
about their stupid corporate jobs I
don't need that my friendship with me
requires you to shut your mouth and let
me speak we sit down we have a lunch I
talk for 45 minutes at the end of the
lunch you I hand you you I will hand you
a script these are the three lines
you're allowed to Sarah I can't believe
you are not more famous it is a tragedy
then you also say everything you do is
so good and it's all moving in the right
direction don't
hurry about it it's gonna be great and
then I say thanks man I appreciate it
and then we leave the restaurant and I
pack and that's a friendship with me
there's nothing else there's no you tell
me about your the office politics it
does the weed shop who cares
oh he goes he said to me one day goes
your businesses so you only have to rely
on yourself I have to rely on all these
other people you'd stop I have to rely
on all these other people there's so
many people there's so many things it's
so hard everybody's dog you know all you
gotta work oh you gotta work you can't
just sit around get high and walk your
dog well welcome to welcome to the races
yeah you gave a bunch of degenerates
office buildings now they're all [ __ ]
legged sword yeah it's easy to sit in
Wendy's and sell dime bags to me and my
dirtbag friends sure it's a little more
difficult now that to go he's like
everybody the government's involved and
regulated hee ha it's what it is you
have a business now you're not just
selling ACE from your mom's Camry I
don't even know what I'm saying at this
point I just know that I'm I am my
righteous anger as well earned and I'm
right know that I'm right I know that my
targets adjust and I'm right
that's all you just have to follow me
folks I'm not saying you should do
oxycontin I'm saying and you can't even
argue me on this it is more adult to be
addicted to percocet than it is to be
high all the time I just respect a
corporate addiction I respect when
someone shows up and they're scratching
because they're on opiates not fentanyl
that's too much too far but I respect a
a person who's you know just addicted to
a kind of a a more exclusive drug that's
all don't smoke weed all the time we
don't need it you don't need it all the
time
it did dims you it dulls you it makes
you
even less interesting than you are super
you're even less interesting than you
are right now with the weed you know
enough with the weed all the time
now we are sponsored by a lot of weed
companies and that now this is awkward
because I do I do want to say that
everything I just said was a bit and a
joke and I don't mean any of it and that
I think weed is great it's natural it's
fun it's sexy and great I want everyone
to do it every minute of every day every
minute of every day I just want to smell
weed I just want to live at Coachella I
want to live in a music festival where
everybody's high all the time and nobody
knows exactly who's talking to who what
what um
I'm kidding we don't we don't have any
weed sponsors but uh I'll just tell you
you know I get it your mind gets melted
and you know I've been addicted to
marijuana alcohol percocet
cocaine vicodin but really led me to
Ferguson I've been addicted to all those
things and you can kick them you can be
done with them and I'm not I'm not
saying that they're all the same but
weed is annoying it's like an annoying
addiction you know it's annoying
it annoys me I would rather you go take
pills in your bathroom and I don't have
to deal with you and you can I can you
we can you can suffer in silence just go
to your desk just take what you need to
and go to your desk I don't want to have
to be inundated with your culture of
your drug you know I used to take
psychedelics I never got into the
culture of psychedelics which is like go
to nature be a better person I never did
that I would take acid and go to the
Garden City hotel and talk about the
fact that the people lived in the next
town over Rockville Center hadn't really
made it I'm like they don't have any
real [ __ ] money okay because I
embraced the material even when I was
high I knew that the material world was
right but the empty it doesn't matter
I go to the [ __ ] I go to the other
realm I'll try to sell the aliens condos
I'll convert them they'll be like we're
all hyper sound it'd be like will you
shut the [ __ ] up do you want a stunning
estate yes or no I don't need the
culture of these drugs you can do a sit
and be a materialistic piece of [ __ ] I
did it for years you don't have to
embrace you don't have to become a
better person on psychedelics you can
find it you could just take shrooms and
touch your friend's dick you don't have
to you don't have to have any great
realizations you can avoid them you can
avoid those you can avoid those
realizations like the plague I get it
for years you don't have to be a better
person while taking psychedelics you can
just be the same shitty person you are
except you see trails that's what it is
how much longer do we have we're at 58
58 we gotta wrap this up cuz we have
some ads and we have some other things
to do what I haven't eaten since lunch I
do need to eat something I will begin
the keto journey again very soon the
keto journey will begin again I've been
off keto because it is very hard to stay
on it because it's very restrictive but
I will be getting back to it very
shortly that keto cookie guy was gonna
sponsor the shower he [ __ ] he [ __ ]
hightail it out of here
[ __ ] you your cookies suck they did they
got sugar alcohols in if they make you
[ __ ] can't have cookies don't eat don't
you can't ever replace my cookies Bryan
Callen saw me when I was on keto three
days he knew and I was like have you
heard of the keto bakery bran Kalecgos
this is not gonna work is it
I was like geez Aikido bakery in Santa
Clarita you guys this is not gonna work
but to bring it full circle here's where
I think about Kobe no I'm kidding he was
a Nikon man he was a Nikon he was not
your dad he wasn't your brother he
wasn't your best friend
folks cherish the people in your lives
that are real I know this shitty I know
they haven't accomplished anything great
I know they don't inspire you I know
many of them smell I know they suck I
know they're fallible they're imperfect
but they're real they're actually there
and many of you they're the people
around you that you deserve you're not
gonna get a kobe to inspire you you just
be inspired by your real uncle who just
got away with a Bailey you know like the
people in your life as shitty as they
are and as unimportant as they are yes
maybe they're not buying estates in
Beverly Hills with blood money maybe
they're not you know leading the Lakers
to a championship but you can reach out
and touch them and say get away from me
that means something cuz they're real
they're actually in your life yes
they're not inspiring figures you're
never gonna look at them and go wow you
know but you could look at them and go
ah they're actually here we're sharing a
physical space that's important you know
it's important that you embrace reality
they're there to disappoint you they're
there to make you feel better when you
fail because they also fail they're
there to be poor with you to be gross
but they're there and that's what's
important embrace them they're the real
heroes the people that you do just a
little better than those are the heroes
the people that you could look at and go
god that guy's a [ __ ] real piece of
[ __ ]
he wound his whole life he threw his
entire life away the kid from your town
died in a car accident that's the guy
you go that guy's dead it wasn't even
his fault he's dead now and you're not
dead and even if you're [ __ ] every
other way you're not dead and that guy
is that should be your Co be the guy
that should inspire you is the scumbag
who's just dead now
not the greatest iconic basketball
player that's amazing and true yeah yeah
yeah yeah but you're not gonna do it
stop it's insulting to him that you like
him so much I'm inspired by people who
own convenience stores like the Indian
guy who keeps a shotgun behind the thing
I like I like that
I go good for him maybe one day I'll be
him you know maybe one day I'll do to go
to another country and open a business
that [ __ ] works it's not easy it's
not easy okay see this is my rant about
that it's you know I you know we covered
a lot today do oxys don't smoke weed go
into real estate if you can because you
can be brain dead and do it and you
should and embrace the real people in
your life all the stars in your life
people like Kobe Bryant or myself we are
there to really you know make you feel
like things are possible but they're but
they're not so embrace the people in
your life that are actually there you
know that fat woman who just puts up
with you she doesn't mind that you have
IBS and then you don't have any money
you know she's not gonna die in a
helicopter she'll never be in a
helicopter an entire life she only been
in a plane once and it was to go to an
all-inclusive resort we threw up all
over your shoes
that's your hero not to be blonde TV not
the people that do great things that
beast of a woman who puts up with you
and and loves you because her father
touched her dad that's America and
that's beautiful
all right P Kobe RI p re goodnight